the chemistry between your main
character Lily and Hagen which was two
dogs was amazing how much time were lily
and the two dogs spending together
offset to bond because they've really
had a chemistry together
absolutely so three months actually
they'd be together but also we we shoot
on a very special method because we
shoot one week and after we rehearse one
week and shoot and rehearse so I I can
say they write the script as well so you
know two children and animals they can
do what they can do and they cannot do
what they cannot do so they cannot lie
right and and that was really
interesting also for me to recognize it
that that how and what they can do and I
write indeed into the script later
so you observed Lily and the two dogs
together to see how they interacted
absolutely I was there most of the time
or tried to be there and and just just
watch them and also just making
propositions and just you know just all
of those things also you know how she's
trumpeting in front of the in front of
hog and hog and knows the music very
well later on because that was the me
piece of music but she's always play and
and yeah you know those elements that
just really writing the script as well
so it was not planned that piece of
music and that's it's coming because of
her so for other filmmakers who are
attempting to work with animals and I
believe you worked with 250 yeah or so
dogs yeah what advice would you give
them because that's such a huge
undertaking they always say children and
animals they'll upstage the production
and what was going on my experience just
almost like a lesson is curiosity and
patient and and freedom is the the three
word I can I can tell you so if you are
curious if you have patient and if you
give them a lots of freedom then they
give a lot lot more energy and emotions
back if you want it to die
damn then it's not working actually I
think it's normal in normal life is also
a lesson it was a lesson for me as well
so that that was it and also you know
just to to wait till the real emotion or
just to play with them like like how you
play with your children's then then then
they they have personality and pleased
to be curious of that personality
because they have different persons
there is not okay they are the dogs you
know it's just stupid like they are the
humans so everybody has their own
personality and if you have time and
curiousity way to shoot that or how they
can communicate that then you have real
persons as humans so I'm sure in this
movies really you can follow them as as
a personality as well it's not just you
know that the general dogs inside right
eye looks that the two dogs would give
Hagen who's the main dog but there were
two dogs yeah
was amazing so what was the trainer
doing to get those looks because at
times you know Hagen was showing fear he
was showing that please don't leave to
Lily a lot of some playfulness at times
what was that trainer doing or trainers
actually they they are playing and that
was really a positive reinforcement
somehow between the trainer and the dogs
and and always I recognize it they are
how much I mean the dogs really try to
give and cooperate always with humans
that's they tasks that stay cold somehow
and and and Teresa it's she was really
open minded and she's really working
with them and playing with that and of
course there are tough emotions in this
movie and you can they feel and they can
show really complex emotions as well
like say sorry and you know just to make
it open love and also like shame in
inside so those emotions are a set and
are in
inside adults but also if you play with
them like with actors they can they can
create and they can give so we counted
at the end and they can use like almost
certain gestures different gestures and
that is almost I mean more than an actor
use it it's really like how they can use
their head for example and and and they
I'm sure they totally understand what
they are doing of course they cannot
sign it with a pen that's okay I'm in a
movie but but they know I mean sometimes
they totally ignore see what they don't
have to do and then we change okay if
you don't want to do that same idea that
you don't do so since there was a sense
of play and a lot of freedom it sounds
like with the dogs in the scenes where
things got scary and there was intensity
how did they react once you yelled cut
and did they know that this was all part
of the scene how are they able to digest
that when you would work with them it's
really difficult to say because because
always they are playing so for example
you know the most rude scenes was for
them it was really playful for example
the fighting scene so we did the
fighting scene it was them in the main
idea behind just you know Bernard who
was the road trailer and and and and
Luke who was the who who fighting I mean
who's who's in the scene know each other
and create them as a best friend and
they have a chemistry there was really
happy always when they meet each other
and then first moment and they meet each
other we shoot and they are champing and
you know just do that all all these
stuff and things together and the shoot
every day 20 minutes that scene and then
in the editing room I have you know the
time just okay but how can I create a
route scene out of this happiness and
then then then the cut I mean the Edit
and the lots of sound is coming and I do
you a first
somehow version and I do more close-ups
you know with the fake blood and you
know those things so that was really
difficult to create out of the happiness
that route seen actually it was
something much more difficult for
example the most difficult was there
when they are just walking on the street
without control so where is the trainer
is not close the camera is not close so
they are just like a bit far away
further away for example there's the
scene when they are just smoking on the
bridge and that is like oh that was more
difficult to create just there alone not
watching us not go anywhere they have
any curiosity just just to walk on this
way that was to create that is more
difficult than than the route seems like
like that and of course they they I'm
sure they know that what they are doing
but they are not I mean as an actor when
it's playful to create so when they are
just stepping to what we shot them legs
and of course we know in the movie that
became very scary not to create it was
not very difficult and how are you
approaching the dogs I realized that the
trainer was there but since you were
letting them play and not and kind of
giving them this like loose rein are you
actually going up to the dogs and if so
how did you what was your body language
like and how did you ask actually I I
was also on the rehearsals almost always
they know me very much also I know them
I cannot say I know all over the 250 but
I know hundreds of them for sure also
named by name everybody had this passage
it's best special skills and and but the
main responsibility has the trainers so
I was always behind the train as always
behind the camera and also my DP was
always and the rehearsals and the set
and also the the sound engineer or the
guy did boom just they understand all of
these circumstances and we build it like
rehearsal place in the countryside so
there were streets and you know just met
because when you are blogged of the city
then you must be fast because it's so
expensive you cannot block it for days
and days and days you can block it for
six hours and only six hours you must
shoot your scene so we do a lot of
rehearsals before and everybody know
what's going on it also the our animal
partners but also the crew members
Cornell the dogs were 250 shelter dogs
is that right no I think it was 200 from
the shelter houses and 50 from from the
trainer's mixed-breed ones okay how does
that work is that different in Hungary
where where you're able to use the dogs
for like maybe eight hours and then take
them back to the shelter how did all
that transpire actually actually less
than eight hours which we should number
four hours maximum also for them hero
dogs beyond Oh you are not able to shoot
more than four hours it's more like
rights for the children's then that also
for rights for the animals and then it
was really interesting because we we met
when I started this movie and the O idea
we met a lots of depressed dogs inside
the shelter houses and then we started
to working together with them as well
and and also with a special method then
how you kill domination fights at eyes
eyes be positive happy gank together who
wanted to cooperate with humans as a
gang and and when we recognize it they
are just you know they changed a lot
they was really like part of the movie
and doesn't want to give them back to
the shelter houses so we do an
adaptation program through the movie we
do our homepage
just you can adopt after the movie those
film star dogs and and it was super
successful so all of them is good
families now and of course we know it's
just the drop in the ocean so 200 was
like adopted
but we try to support as much as we can
also those programs and and shelter
houses as myself personally as well and
and also our film company is supporting
with good money so as white god a film
about animal rights or is it a larger
message about overcoming being unwanted
and a story of two people separated or
two creatures really separated I think
it's a social criticism I criticize my
society my major society to create those
stories and I mean it's it's about
animal rights of course but I was not a
huge animal ride fighter before but
after this movie I am and I am facing
with those problems
I felt I would like to live in a society
there have rights also the animals and
also the plants and every everyone have
the same rights I'm deeply believe in
equality and I felt I I think we shared
the word so and which is human easily
forget this is bird just for us and it's
just simply not true and and of course
it's always asunder for the society as
well
how much rights has animals inside
beautiful thank you thank you so much